قبل 43 عامًا من
خلال قانون العلاقات التايوانية ، قطعت أمريكا
وعدًا راسخًا بالوقوف دائمًا مع
تايوان
[موسيقى]
وعلى هذا الأساس القوي ، قمنا
ببناء شراكة مزدهرة ترتكز على
قيمنا المشتركة للحكم
الذاتي وتقرير المصير التي
تركز على  مصلحتنا الأمنية المتبادلة
في المنطقة وفي جميع أنحاء العالم
ملتزمة بالروابط الاقتصادية
التي تعزز الازدهار لجميع شعبنا
[موسيقى]
نريد زيادة
التعاون
والحوار بين البرلمانات ونفعل ذلك في الوقت
الذي قدم فيه رئيسنا  مبادرة آسيا والمحيط الهادئ
التي
ندعمها ونريد أن نكون محددين من حيث
كيفية عملنا مع تايوان في هذا الصدد
ومن حيث الحكم ، نشيد
بتايوان لكونها واحدة من المجتمعات الحرة
في
العالم لنجاحك في مخاطبة الطمع.
قضية مصلحة وهي قضية صحية ، قضية
أمنية ، قضية اقتصادية
وقضية حوكمة ، نهنئك على
[موسيقى]
، يحق للمتحدث زيارة
تايوان.
وزار المتحدث باسم المنزل
تايوان من قبل بدون حوادث
كما فعل العديد من أعضاء الكونجرس على
مدار السنوات بما في ذلك هذا العام
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
أه